Super Mario maker was one of the biggest
games of 2015 and now you'll be able to
play it on the go I'm Tony and this is
your custom-made gamespot news update
for the most part Mario maker on 3ds is
the same Wii U game you remember the
game comes with 100 built-in levels and
of course you can still build your own
but where the console version encourages
you to share levels online the 3ds port
is all about sharing locally with
friends to that end you can send and
receive levels via StreetPass what's
more you can collaborate on levels by
sharing works in progress you'll also be
able to download select Wii U courses
but it's important to note that you
can't upload your creations online Super
Mario maker comes to 3ds on December
second the original game was a runner-up
for gamespot so in game of the year in
2015 so consider that a strong
endorsement creating and sharing levels
with friends ain't so bad either to keep
up with all the biggest Nintendo news
you're already in the right place
you